Steve Kaufman here it's a bit of a
miserable day here in Vancouver it's
cloudy and overcast and I have a cold so
don't be surprised if I break out into a
cough here but I thought I would follow
up my recent videos where I talked about
frustrations that we sometimes feel in
language learning and talk a little bit
about how do we know if we're
progressing in a language I want to talk
about that subject and then if I have
time or maybe in the in a subsequent
video I'll answer a question that I
received from a teacher an English
teacher in Japan who asked me you know
given that the role of the teacher is to
motivate primarily to motivate student
and given that there are so many
resources available today just what
should be the role of a teacher in a
classroom now I can offer my opinions on
that probably in the next video
based on never having been a teacher in
a classroom but at the based on my
experience as a learner both in the
classroom and outside the classroom but
before we get to that let's talk about
this business of how do we know if we're
making progress first of all the simple
answer is we know I know when I'm able
to say more things or when I understand
more in language the problem is that the
improvement is so slow that often we go
for long stretches without feeling that
we've made any progress so what should
we do and you know I mentioned in one of
my earlier previous videos about these
sort of technical terms that are used in
the you know second language acquisition
industry terms like inter language which
say that as you are learning another
language you will obviously be
influenced by your native language and
therefore you will continue to produce
patterns or even pronunciation or use
words or sayings that come from your
native language and that this will
influence you when you speak another
language
and I made the point that that of course
that's true and I know many people for
example who speak English very well in
particular Swedes who are very good at
English and they will always use certain
Swedish construction constructions like
instead of saying there are many people
in China they'll say it is many people
in China that's a very Swedish
construction and they'll you know their
essays are there I was listening we were
listening with my wife to a Swedish
commentator on a golf program and you
can tell that she's Swedish she is
influenced by her native language in use
of words in structure in pronunciation
but to me that doesn't mean that she's
speaking in her language she is speaking
English and she is probably well this
the announcer not the people and I know
I'm referring now to Swedish speaking
people who speak English very very well
they don't need to get beyond that
they're already to do and doing very
very well
if they wanted to focus on some of these
expressions that are a little bit
Swedish they probably could get rid of
them if they wanted to or maybe they
can't it really doesn't matter they're
very good at communicating in English
the problem is not when we get to that
stage where we kind of let our
shirttails hang out every now and again
as an Anglicism slips into our Russian
or French or or whatever the problem is
when we're starting out and for a good
long period we have the feeling that
we're forever unable to say what we want
we don't quite understand the movie we
don't quite understand what people are
saying and and we sort of feel that
we're not making any progress and I
refer to this earlier when I said you
know don't get frustrated just focus on
doing things that you enjoy doing okay
but then if we do focus on doing things
that we enjoy doing how do we know that
we're making progress okay to me I like
the word count now and I know that's
quite controversial and it's very much
central to what we do at link but I know
for example in in Czech I've been at it
since August my goal by the way when I
start into a language is not immediately
to speak it because I think that's very
difficult and I
I'm not convinced that it's a good thing
to try to do because you may in fact if
he spent a lot of time speaking
improperly you may ingrain those habits
and you know to me language learning is
about two things in a way it's about
repetition and it's about stimulating
the brain with new things so you've got
to have a mixture of repetition and a
mixture of new stimulating interesting
things so you're mixing the two but if
you're doing too much repetition with a
very narrow vocabulary base and with
improper structure and improper
pronunciation that's what you're getting
used to that's what you're hearing
similarly if we sit in a classroom say
we're Japanese and we sit in the
classroom with other Japanese people who
are learning English most of the
Japanese that we hear in the classroom
is what the other non-native speakers
are saying so I'm not a great fan of
that I would far rather listen to a
native speaker I might have to just take
this briefly and see who it is
hello can I call you back I'm in the
middle of the video you're in the art
okay right yeah so this interruption
there so what I was saying was that so I
don't like being in a classroom because
I'm hearing and I'm in grading and I'm
basically repeating a form of the
language that I don't want so we want to
repeat and we want novelty and to me
that's listening in reading okay but how
do I know that I'm getting anywhere well
I know because I've done it so often I
know for example in the case of my
Russian that as I listened more and more
and as I read more and more slowly I
started to be able to speak better Anna
then started to speak more and more but
what was my gauge that I was actually
making progress
well that gauge is the number of words
that I know and that's why we make that
the main metric at link now it's kind of
like a leading indicator you have to do
a lot of other things you can't study
these words from wordless you have to
learn them through a lot of listening
and reading you also should save phrases
but the one easy thing to measure the
sort of Gordian knot is a
whereas you know now people are gonna
say well you know how do you know if you
know them you know them passively you
can't use them I don't care if I can
understand them in a context I'm happy
because my goal is to understand and I
know that if I build up my ability to
understand that's a very solid base from
which to start speaking if your ability
to speak gets a hand of your ability to
understand you'll be in for some
difficult times because you'll say
something you won't understand about
people say back to now in check up and
added since August the link tells me
that I know 20,000 words I don't really
know 20,000 words but I know that two
months ago I only know I only knew say
10,000 so now I know 20,000 so I know
with every day as I'm continuing to work
at it I am increasing my vocabulary and
I also know as I download text from Jeff
newspapers on the web that I understand
more and more of it but there's more and
more of these words that in fact I do
know albeit passively so to me a very
good measure of whether or not we're
progressing is this number of words that
you know because it means that your
comprehension is increasing whether in
fact it's 20,000 or because check is a
very inflected language it equates to
5,000 words in English whenever it
doesn't matter it's not from bragging
rights it's in order to demonstrate to
yourself that in fact you are continuing
to progress and if you continue to
progress and your vocabulary
you know the words known number
continues to increase you will
understand better and better
you will read more material you don't as
your meeting or come across some of the
words that you really know and some of
them be more or less know and you'll be
constantly reading and exposing yourself
to the language and your comprehension
will improve and that to me is the
number one thing when you have a strong
sense of understand you know ability
understand the language then you start
speaking now there are people say well
you know I can read very well but I
can't speak and I always ask them I've
had this is good discussion many times
and I said well you read very well so
then for example are you comfortable
reading a novel would you go and grab a
novel people say immigrants encounters
say you know I can't speak very well but
I read very well we Chinese read very
well I could often hear that
so I with a group of say 50 China
people in the lecture once I said so how
many people here willingly pick up a
novel and read it just like that as
something that they enjoy doing
nobody well to read well you gotta enjoy
reading it's not that you can pick your
way through a short you know article
you've never read books and similarly
with listening
do you enjoy audiobooks you know do you
understand most of what's on the radio
this is where you got to get to in your
comprehension to do that you need words
because the biggest thing is if you if
you're missing a word now I know we also
want to learn phrases and so forth but
phrases are composed of words if very
often and I know also that 80% of any
context consists of the 2000 most
frequently used words but it's the other
20% that determine the meaning so
measuring the words you know and and
having you know a way of staying on top
of the fact that you are constantly
increasing your vocabulary through these
input based activities to my mind is a
good indicator that you are improving
and when you have a certain level of of
vocabulary and I'm not there yet in my
check I'd like to have another 10,000
words and do a lot more listening and
then I'm gonna start speaking more I've
spoken a couple of times it's been very
difficult but I'm quite convinced that
some other people who maybe start
speaking earlier will be ahead of me as
a bit of a sort of tortoise and hare
situation the hare will jump ahead of me
they'll be able to say more things in
check very early but in the long run
after six months I'm convinced that I
will be able to do more of my check in
terms reading listening having
intelligent conversations with people on
a variety of subjects so there's a
quickie then on and that's a theme that
I've talked about before and that is you
know I'm not gonna find awarenesses I've
gotta find my cursor yeah words keep up
your word count and you'll get there
that is the as I've described before
it's the basically the little mechanical
rabbit at the dog race it's something
that keeps you going so thank you for
listening oh and I should add that
obviously these words have to be gleaned
through things that you enjoy doing so
listening
music if you like in song they're
listening to audiobooks or reading some
you know books or articles but
constantly pushing yourself a little
further and further ahead and increasing
your known word count thank you for
listening bye for now